Speaker 1: Let's see, why don't
we speak next to how about Danny
from Los Angeles. Danny, you're on the air.
Speaker 3: Hey, David, can you hear me? Yes,
I can. Pleasure to talk to you. Give me a lot
of good talking points. Thank you. Thank you
for that pleasure. I just have this question we're
seeing from what I read. And there's like people
are talking about this sort of this red scare.
I'm coming back a new Red Scare McCarthyism,
because I'm curious about what your thoughts
are, because we seem like because I'm a Zouma.
So a bunch of my friends, they see the
flaws in unregulated capitalism. And so
we're seeing, like, you know, DeSanto saying like,
oh, liberal schools are indoctrinating children.
In reality, I don't think that because my school
like even like I live in Los Angeles. So my
college allows, like Republican clubs and stuff.
But then if you do a social club, it's like, oh,
that's way too extreme. So I just want to.
Speaker 1: So what are you saying? That
your school shut down a socialist club on campus?
Speaker 3: No, like any sort of not my school.
Because a democratic socialist, they're
allowed. But like, if they say like
communist or like any like hsueh, if they don't
have, like, Democrat, they would like kind of they
would label as like an extreme in a way.
Speaker 1: So your school has said that
communist groups would not be allowed.
Speaker 3: They never explicitly say that. But
but they're the teachers kind of don't like it.
Speaker 1: They the teachers don't like it. So,
OK, I'm let's not let's step back from that just a
little bit, because it's not that that piece isn't
making a whole lot of sense to me. When you say a
new red scare, you're basically just saying that
the right is going to play up fears of communism
and socialism invading the United States.
Speaker 3: Yes. This reactionary
Speaker 1: that's happening. That's happening. And
you're seeing it. I mean, listen, part of the
reason it's happening is that over the last ten or
so years, Republicans have moved away completely
from policy. There's no more policy. I mean,
think, think, think. CPAC this past weekend,
there was no discussion of policy beyond just
very vague, like we just need guns in more places.
We can't make people get vaccines. We got to keep
people from getting indoctrinated. There's no
positive proposal, affirmative proposal about
how to deliver health care, et cetera. So what
do you replace it with? You replace it with scare
rhetoric about the other side. And part of it is
the sort of communism socialism stuff. And, you
know, let's just be really honest about this. I'm
not a communist. I'm not a socialist. I don't want
the US to be a communist or socialist country. But
I recognize that there's no immediate risk of that
at all. There's no communists or socialists in
positions of power. Joe Biden is a capitalist.
And, you know, we've just got to be honest about
that. But it's not surprising that in the absence
of policy, they go to fear mongering rhetoric.
Speaker 3: Yeah, so do you think it would be
like that to the extreme of McCarthyism at
that time or it's just going to be like,
you know, what they're doing kind of right now?
Speaker 1: Everything is so different today
than it was during the McCarthy era that no, I
don't think it's the same thing. I think it's
probably reductive and inaccurate to say it's
a new McCarthyism. We have something going on
right now that's disgusting and horrible, but
it's not McCarthyism. Now, I wouldn't say that.
Speaker 3: OK, you know, I was just
curious because a second thought video
came out and I thought it was it
said like a new red scare. I thought
that it had some pretty good information.
Speaker 1: So, yeah, I mean, listen, I don't
have any problem with people calling it a new red
scare. It probably gets clicks. It's something
people might identify with in practice. I think
we have sort of its own thing where there was a
different. The reason that it's happening now is
a Republican Party that has completely abandoned,
abandoned, even pretending to care about
policy. And they're filling the void with fear.
The motivations for the McCarthy era were
different. The rhetoric may be similar,
though, that I will concede.
Speaker 3: OK, thank you so much,
David. My pleasure. Take care.
Speaker 1: You, too, very much.
Appreciate the call. Let's go to a quick break and
we will be back with much more right after this.